اربع مباريات جرت يوم امس في الجوله
الثالثه من دوري المجموعات لكاس العالم
لكن كل الاضواء كانت مسلطه على مباراه
واحده وعنوانها ايران تواجه الولايات
المتحده مباراه بعناوين كثيره المباراه
المسيسه مباراه الثار من خساره عمرها ربع
قرن ومباراه الحرب الرياضيه وفي كل
الاحوال هي مباراه مجالها اوسع من المربع
الاخضر وفي النتيجه الولايات المتحده
استطاعت بعد 24 عاما استطاعت الثار من
ايران في البطوله نفسها وغلبتها بهدف
الوحيد اقصاها خارج المنافسه ابناء العم
سام تاهل الى الدور المقبل فيما حزم
الايرانيون انت عتهم لمغادره اللوحه بعد
فقدانهم فرصه تاهل للدوري المقبل وهكذا
تلتقي السياسه والرياضه في لحظات تاريخيه
نرجع الى ابرز تلك هذه اللحظات
[تصفيق]
ملاحم كرويه كانت في ظاهرها رياضيه لكن
بعطينها امتلا بابعاد سياسيه عديده شهد
عليها تاريخ كاس العالم عبر نسخه الاثنين
والعشرين الماضيه في نسخه كاس العالم
الثالثه عام
1938 خيمه الحساسيه على لقاء منتخب
ايطاليا الذي كان يمثل الفاشيه الايطاليه
في اوروبا ومنتخب فرنسا الذي قابل النشيد
الايطالي بصفارات الاستهجان في يوم فازت
فيه ايطاليا بثلاثه اهداف لهدف ايضا
مونديال المانيا عام
1974 كان موعدا للقاء الاشقاء الاعداء حيث
اجتمع منتخبا المانيا الشرقيه والغربيه في
ذلك الوقت بلقاء مشحون سياسيا انهته
المانيا الشرقيه بهدف باقي في الذاكره حتى
بعد هدم جدار برلين ولم الارجنتينيون حرب
جزر فوكلاند مع بريطانيا في مونديال
المكسيك عام 86 كانت حربا من نوع اخر في
استاد استيكه المكسيكيه الذي كان شاهدا
على هدفين تاريخيين للراحل مارادونا اقصيت
خلالهما انجلترا من الدوره ربع النهائي
لبطوله كاس العالم وفي مونديال فرنسا عام
98 كانت الاجواء متوتره للغايه بين
الولايات المتحده وايران لكن الرياضه
حكمتهما بلقاء اعتقد انه سيكون مليئا
بالحساسيه الا ان لاعبي المنتخبين وجدوه
فرصه للتهدئه تصافحوا وتبادلوا التذكارات
وفازت ايران في النهايه مسجله اولا
انتصارا ممتعلي لها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تفضلي
انه في مين انتشرت على من الميمز اللي
انتشر على السوشيال ميديا بيقولوا لك
ولاول مره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وايران بيلعبوا خارج العراق فقط
[تصفيق]
اخطر متى تلتقي السياسه بالرياض الرياضه
وكيف تؤثر السياسه على اللعبه الاكثر
شعبيه في العالم
السياسه خلينا نقول متداخله في الرياضه
بشكل غير عادي المقوله اللي بتتردد انه لا
علاقه بين السياسه والرياضه دائما كنا
بنقولها في الميديا والمؤسسات الرياضيه
العالميه دائما ترددها بس اسمحيلي ما
ينفعش اقول التعبير ده الصبح بس انا هقوله
مقوله كذبه الرياضه والسياسه تداخل باتم
معنى الكلمه مباراه الامس اكبر دليل
مباراه لها ظل سياسي كبير خلينا نقول 60
الى 70% من الناس اللي كانت بتشاهد
المباراه بالامس لا علاقه لهم بالكره
القدم هم رايحين نشوفوا كلمه ساوند ايران
مع امريكا ازاي في كره القدم سياسيه مش
كره قدم في تداخل غير عادي بين السياسه
والرياضه ويجب ان نعترف به طيب
صور شفنا كثير مواقف لنا ناس يلبسوارات
تسليط الضوء على قضايا
هي مجتمعيه شفنا حتى ايرانيات حاملين صور
لمهسا امينه اللي قتلها النظام الايراني
اليوم ما هو الخط الفاصل بين المواقف
السياسيه في الرياضه وبين انه تسليط الضوء
على قضايا سياسيه مجتمعيه انسانيه في هذا
الكوكب في حدث رياضي مثل كره كاس العالم
اجتماعي رياضي وليس حدث رياضي فقط
فبالتالي الاضواء كلها مسلطه على هذه
البقعه الان ما لديه قضيه يبدا في التعبير
عنها انا بالنسبه لي بالنسبه لي اتمنى ان
تكون الرياضه بعيده بدرجه كبيره عن
السياسه بس لا احد يستطيع فصلهم لا احد
يستطيع ابدا فصل السياسه عن الرياضه ولكن
بالنسبه لي مساله لان في جانب اخر لازم
نفكر فيه
هذا المنتخب يمثل منه
هذا المنتخب يمثل من يمثل الوطن في
النهايه بصرف النظر عن الاطراف المتسرعه
وبالمناسبه كل طرف من هذه الاطراف يحاول
جذب المنتخبين اليه وبالتالي اللاعب نفسه
تحت ضغط مش طبيعي يعني يعني يردد النشيد
الوطني لم يردد النشيد الوطني
تصنيف جمهوري ينتمي لمن ففي النهايه اذا
لم تكن الروح ان هذا المنتخب يمثل الوطن
بصرف النظر عن اي تجابات وفي النهايه اذا
لم يكن الهدف اسعاد هذا الجمهور فالمساله
بتكون صعبه جدا ومتداخله بشكل لا يمكن
فصله ابدا
تؤثر السياسه على كره القدم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رياضه ممكن تقرب كثير بين الشعوب
وتدي رساله كويسه للسياسه يعني زي ما شفنا
مثلا
مقابله السيسي مع اردوغان
تصفيه الخلافات ما بين السعوديه وقطر مجرد
مناسبه عالميه
يجتمعوا فيها فممكن تذوب
الاثار الجانبيه لاي علاقه سياسيه والامور
ديت يعني
دي بعدين
هيبقى التاثير اكبر انما لو في علاقات
التاثير ممكن يبقى طبيعي اصلا ومالوش
لازمه زي روسيا مثلا روسيا الان استعملت
موضوع همم موضوع كره القدم سياسيا لسبب
دخولها هي وكرانيا في بعض الاحيان بتقرب
المسافات السياسيه او بتزيل الحواجز
السياسيه يعني لا طبعا اكيد مش بتاثر لان
احنا تعودنا من من الطفوله ان رابط
التشجيع للفريق المحب عمره ما كان يختلط
بالسياسه عمري ما كان مثلا همم الرئيس ده
رئيس النادي ده يبقى في الحزب ده او
بيتابع للسياسه دي الكوره شيء والسياسه شئ
ثاني اللي انا شايفه ان السياسه بيتراعي
وبتصرف ملايين الدولارات على اللاعيبه
بحيث ان يبقى عندهم رياضه
شوف الاهلي شوفوا الفرق الكبيره همم
ريال مدريد اسبانيا اللي هي الفرق برشلونه
الفرقه دي دلوقت بتعمل اقتصاد في السياسه
والشغل عالي جدا النهارده النهارده فعلا
ده حقيقه الكوره بقت تعتبر سياسه
[تصفيق]
الشارع يعني بعض المباريات الرياضيه فعلا
تستقبل اهتمام سياسيين قبل الشارع الرياضي
لما تحمله من طابع متوتر يطغى على كره
القدم كيف تؤثر السياسه هذه المره على كره
القدم
لحظه لحظه بالنسبه له لابد ان يستغلها انا
انا من غير المحبين لدخول السياسه في
الرياض الرياضه شيء بيور جميل وتحديدا كاس
العالم وكره القدم و منين اضمن ان السياسي
في هذه اللحظه لا يريد استغلال هذه اللعبه
الجميله لعبه الشعوب مساله غير مضمومه
يعني هو في النهايه يبحث عن مكسب سياسي
الجمهور بالمناسبه مباراه الامس على مستوى
المنافسه بين اللاعبين وعلى مستوى حتى
الجمهور لان ما فيش فصل بين الجماهير في
كاس العالم بالمناسبه الناس كانوا زي الفل
علاقه عاديه علاقه انسانيه لا علاقه لهم
ابدا باي تجاذب سياسي او باي خلافات او
باي مشاكل وده اروع ما في الرياضه
منتخب بلاده في هذه الحاله يلعب امام خصمه
وليس خصم رياضي بل خصم سياسي بدهنه بفكره
هي تعتمد انا انا
تصورينا نتكلم بصراحه يعني في الجانب
الايراني ربما يكون احنا شعبنا او شعوب
المنطقه عندها اهتمام بالسياسه انا اتصور
اللاعب الامريكي معظمهم يعني اتصور ليس
لدي معلومه انه لم يكن لديه اصلا معلومه
يعني ما المشكله اساسا وبالتالي ده في راي
كمان انعكس على الاداء
ويمكن لاحظنا ده في الاداء اللي الامريكان
او المنتخب الامريكي امبارح كان متحرر من
ظهور لو نظرنا للبعض لان مش تبع اللاعبين
الايرانيين والطباعاتهم
في في حاله من التشتت الذهني في شد عصبي
على الجانب الاخر منتخب الامريكي كان
بيلعب باريحيه اكثر اتصور المساله
مرجعيتها انه في طرف طب بشحنه بشكل سياسي
والطرف الاخر يلعب كره القدم
هي الحرب الوحيده التي تنتهي بالعين
وتبادل تحايا بدون مفاوضات في مباراه
الجزيره شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
اليوم في مباراه بين ايران وامريكا يعني
رد اثنين اعداء مع بعض عم يلعبوا فطبول
يعني
رياضه رياضه الي بتفكر بالسياسه ما بتزبط
ابطال من العالم اجمعين مجموعين كلهم
[موسيقى]
حتى لو ايران وامريكا عم بيلعب ضد بعض
يعني مو ضروري يدخلوا السياسه بالفوتبول
يعني الفوتبول هاي الرياضه يعني والله كره
القدم منا
ميسي كره القدم تجمع كل العالم
[موسيقى]